hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse Orion comm and in this video I
want to show you how to check that
Achilles deep tendon reflex so let me
show you how it's done
okay now let's check the Achilles
Achilles is going to look for l5 - s2
and this is best done having the patient
dangle their feet just like whenever
you're checking the patellar you usually
want to check those two together and
what you're going to do is you're going
to Dorse dorsiflex the foot up like that
and you will see the tendon which is
located right above the heel and it's
right there and what we're going to do
is we're looking for the fit - plantar
flex so it's going to go down like that
- Lissa responds but in order to do it
you're going to dorsi flex the foot by
supporting your hand underneath it and
just tapping the bottom of it and flex
eluting okay so that is how you check
that deep tendon reflex now check out my
other videos on how to check the other
for deep tendon reflexes and consider
subscribing to this YouTube channel